[Music]  amy adams takes on a dark new role in  sharp objects it was just such a  different character than I'd played  before the HBO thriller is based on a  book by the writer of gone girl and Amy  plays a reporter with a drinking problem  who returns to her hometown to solve a  murder mystery I'm just in town on  business  come and look I'm glad you're home each  day on set Amy spent two hours naked in  front of makeup artists so they could  transform her for the role adding  bruises to her body  I said hallelujah Amy Adams is broken  messy like what I look like  I was like you really just made them let  them make you look bad and I think yes  yes I do  [Music]